please give a very warm one young world
welcome to the co-founder of archwell
megan the duchess of sussex
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
well good evening everyone
it is
very nice to be back in the uk
and
it is very nice to be back with all of
you at one young world
as you'll likely hear
many times this week look as we just
heard you'll hear all sorts of things
some very heavy
some very uplifting but the resounding
spirit i believe you'll hear is that you
are the future
but i would like to add to that
that you are also
the present
you are the ones driving the positive
and necessary change needed across the
globe now in this very moment
and for that
i'm so grateful to be in your company
today
it was several years ago in 2014
that i was first invited to be a
counselor at one young world
and in many ways at the time
i was probably a lot like each of you
young
ambitious advocating for the things i
deeply and profoundly believed in
and also looking around and wondering
how on earth did i get here
have any of you today so far had that
feeling that pinch me moment where you
just go how am i here
oh it's a lot and at that dinner there
were about
20 to 30 of us for the counselors and
there i was i was the girl from suits
and i was
surrounded by
world leaders humanitarians prime
ministers an activist that i had such a
deep and long-standing respect and
admiration for
and i was invited
to pull up a seat at the table
i was so overwhelmed by this experience
i think
i think i even saved my little paper
place card that said my name on it
um
just proof
proof that i was there
and proof
that i belonged
because the truth was i wasn't sure that
i belonged
i was so nervous
oh i doubted myself and i wondered i
wondered if i was good enough to even be
there if what i was doing in the world
albeit important and meaningful as far
as i saw it was it deserving
to have a seat at this table
but one young world
saw in me
what i wanted to see fully in myself
they saw in me
just as i see in you
the present
and the future
and i reiterate that point because
oftentimes we speak to young adults
about the years ahead
about what you'll do
what you'll have to adopt to fix from
previous generations
and also what legacy you will leave
but too often in that
we neglect the point
that you're doing it
now you hear
in this present moment
this is where it's all beginning
the first year i joined the delegation
in dublin i worked with a young woman
from eritrea
and she described how she had
escaped her home country fleeing with
bullets fired
above her head
i still remember it so well i remember
my shock
i also remember her
courage my recognition of how much
continues to go on each day
with so many turning a blind eye and yet
despite all odds
she like so many
still
persevered
i followed up that trip as david
mentioned to joining the delegation
again in 2016 in ottawa
i was very lucky to receive a day off of
filming specifically
to take a quick flight from toronto
up to ottawa and to be able to join this
work again for one young world
being with some people that i admired
most including former president of
ireland mary robinson who you heard from
earlier
i joined you in london in 2019 and by
that point it's fair to say
my life had changed rather significantly
i was now married
and i was now a mom
[Applause]
[Music]
my
world view had expanded exponentially
seeing the global community
through the eyes of my child
and i would ask what is this world he
would come to adopt
and what can we do what can i do to make
it better
i am thrilled that my husband is able to
join me here this time
[Applause]
to
be able to see and witness firsthand my
respect for this organization this
incredible organization and all that it
provides as well as accomplishes
one young world has been an integral
part of my life for so many years before
i met him
so to meet again here on uk soil with
him by my side makes it all feel full
circle
and just as a sidebar earlier this
afternoon we sat down with a few of you
delegates
and it was incredibly inspiring the
resounding themes that came up
about representation
about inclusion
about access
and about trying to shift the global
perspective for all of us as a global
community
to one of curiosity
over criticism
my husband has long advocated for
important and necessary impact in the
world focusing a huge part of his life's
work on the youth
so for both of us
bearing witness to the power
that you hold in your hands
and the unbridled enthusiasm and energy
that you have to see things come to
fruition
it is just an absolute privilege
i'm incredibly humbled to not just stand
before each of you
but to stand beside you
we often hear people say the time is now
but i'm going to double down on that
by saying your time is now
the important work
can't wait for tomorrow
and this week the world is watching as
you cement your place in history
by showcasing the good that you are
doing today
in the present moment
as we embrace the moment of now
to create a better tomorrow
and with that it is my absolute honor
and pleasure to declare this year's one
young world summit officially open
[Music]
you